Traduttore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Revisore: Maurizio Berti
(rumore bianco)
[Non si può più aspettare.
Spingi!
Dai, un respiro!
Ecco le gambe.
Ancora, forza, deve
uscire anche la testa!
Eccola,
La prendo io.
Ventila.
Il tubo non passa,
c'è un'ostruzione in gola.
Ventila.
Provo ancora!
Ecco, è passato.
E' viva!
La porto su.
(rumore bianco)
[Fuori/Dentro]
Io sono quella mamma prematura.
E vorrei portarvi oggi la voce
di chi è stato
fuori e dentro a una termoculla.
Affronteremo insieme un doppio dialogo
dove io parlerò con voi
e chi è là dentro
parlerà con me.
Là dentro c'è un grande prematuro.
Questo è un grande prematuro.
Pesa 531 grammi,
è lunga 27 cm
il cuore batte
ma non respira.
C'è una cannuccia che scende
fino ai polmoni
li gonfia e sgonfia di ossigeno
e potrebbe da un momento all'altro
(soffia)
soffiare via.
Punto uno.
La realtà.
Uno su dieci nasce prima.
Tre su 10.000 così tanto prima
da essere considerati tecnicamente
un aborto spontaneo
anche se vivi.
Cosa vuol dire "così tanto prima"?
Prima della ventiquattresima settimana:
cinque mesi e mezzo.
La "bottiglietta", là dentro,
è nata alla ventitreesima.
La percentuale di sopravvivenza
è molto meno del lancio di una monetina:
tre su dieci.
La probabilità di sviluppare disabilità:
è molto meglio non pensarci.
Allora,
ho capito che:
sono viva,
per ora,
sono rara
e per il futuro si vedrà.
Punto due:
la mansarda.
La termoculla io la chiamavo così.
Piccola, umida, buia,
e con le tende sempre chiuse.
A me mi sembra una capsula
e io ho fatto un viaggio
spaziotemporale:
ne sono sicura, sono arrivata
quattro mesi prima!
La gravità mi spiaccica,
la luce mi acceca,
i suoni mi assordano,
ma non sono mica la prima:
anche Superman è arrivato
con una capsula!
E allora, qual'è la mia missione?
Punto tre:
la barriera.
Signori, la mia barriera si apriva,
era una finestra:
l'oblò della termoculla.
"La vuoi vedere un attimo?"
No.
"La vuoi toccare un attimo?"
Io la guardavo,
ma non vedevo mia figlia.
D'altronde,
non l'avevo sentita muoversi
neppure una volta
nella mia pancia.
Mi costringevo a non amare qualcosa
che poteva morire in un istante.
E' una colpa?
Ah, ho capito qual'è la mia missione:
dare tutti i giorni degli schiaffi
in faccia alla mia mamma
finché non smette di avere
quell'espressione catatonica
e poi metterla tutta quanta:
testa, mani e piedi
in un secchio
e sommergerla di amore.
E tu,
omone con la barba
che mi chiami "formichina",
chi sei?
Il babbo?
Ti perdono che non eri
in sala parto
solo perché la prima volta
che mi hai guardato
avevi già il cervello che era
una frittata a forma di cuore.
Allora,
anche Batman aveva una spalla
e io ho bisogno di una mano
in questa missione
che si chiama "mamma".
Punto quattro:
il parentado.
Io capisco l'entusiasmo di accogliere
ogni nuovo nato,
son fatta così,
ma io mi sentivo dire:
"È già nata?
Sai, il mio vicino di casa
50 anni fa è nato prima
l'hanno messo in una scatola da scarpe
e adesso sta benissimo.
Possiamo venire a trovarla?
Capiamoci:
ha un ago che da qui
arriva in mezzo al torace,
uno nell'ombelico,
un tubo dritto nei polmoni,
uno nello stomaco,
una luce rossa intorno a un piede
e la pelle,
completamente trasparente,
che si ulcera solo a guardarla!
No. Non credo che sopravviverebbe
in una scatola da scarpe.
Ma io dico:
se una persona
che non avete mai conosciuto prima
viene ricoverata
fra la vita e la morte
in una terapia intensiva
vi verrebbe mai in mente
di chiedere se la si può
andare a trovare?
Stabile. Stabile. Instabile.
Signora, c'è un'infezione generalizzata
abbiamo scelto un antibiotico che arrivi
a coprire anche il cervello.
Cosa?
Ma come?
Cioè, 30 minuti fa stava benino,
mi sta lasciando?
(suono di dispositivo
per la ventilazione meccanica)
All'appello!
Wolverine, Capitan America,
Deadpool!
Ok amichetti miei,
non mi sento proprio in forma,
voi ci siete già passati:
vi hanno già iniettato delle
sostanze superpotenzianti e...
a volte penso che
il dolore sia troppo.
Ho paura
di non riuscire a farcela.
Ma voi ce l'avete fatta,
siete diventati più forti di prima,
datemi una mano
perché devo continuare a dare
degli schiaffi alla mia mamma
e mi tocca resistere!
Punto cinque:
i canguri.
Forse, alcuni di voi,
lo sanno già,
ma quando il piccolo canguro nasce,
pesa un grammo
ed è lungo 2 cm.
Percorre come può la distanza
fra l'utero e il marsupio
e una volta lì si attacca
con la bocca ad una mammella
e non la lascia più
per due o tre mesi.
Le mamme premature
in fondo fanno come
le mamme canguro:
solo che i loro cuccioli
si attaccano alla terapia intensiva,
qualche mese,
e i loro cangurini li appoggiano
sul torace.
Si chiama "marsupio-terapia".
Mi hanno chiesto se la "marsupio"
è stata una gioia grande.
La prima volta che l'ho sentita
qua,
volevo squarciarmi il torace
e rinfilarcela dentro.
Immediatamente.
No, decisamente, prima è stato
un enorme dolore,
ma poi, lei, mi ha toccato
salvandomi l'anima.
E io le ho detto:
"sì" ogni giorno".
Mani e macchine
mi allacciano alla vita come una spina.
Ma tu dove sei?
Mi servi!
Dove sei?
Tocco dolce a mano ferma.
Una sul mio capo,
l'altra sotto i piedi.
Sarai il mio confine,
mamma.
E io sarò la tua preghiera.
Eccoti, calmati.
La senti la macchina che è
attaccata ai miei polmoni?
Suona perché io non le dò retta!
Voglio respirare
insieme a te.
Punto sei.
Le somiglianze.
E niente, quel tubo nei polmoni
non lo si riusciva a togliere:
senza, non reggeva.
Era un continuo togli e metti,
togli e metti.
Un pomeriggio, mentre il dottore
era pronto a ripiantarglielo nella gola,
la guardava e mi disse:
"è bella, sai, ti assomiglia."
Mi interessa solo che sia VIVA!
Mamma,
allora, mi misurano continuamente la testa
perché è piccola,
la pancia è grossa
e dall'ombelico esce della roba,
e mi hanno detto
che presto inizieranno a puntarmi
delle luci negli occhi
per capire quanto sono cieca.
Anche La Cosa dei Fantastici 4
Deadpool e Bestia degli X-men
non sono esattamente
icone di bellezza,
in ogni caso, io,
mi sento discretamente figa
e sì, te lo assicuro,
sono viva!
Punto sette:
L'Agenda Bianca.
Quanti di voi hanno, usano,
un'agenda, nel telefono, in tasca?
In terapia intensiva neonatale
le agende sono bianche,
non ci sono ore,
nè giorni,
nè settimane.
Ci sono solo i complemesi.
E sul fondo di ogni pagina
c'è una linea rossa incostante:
stabile, stabile, instabile.
Un pomeriggio,
qua,
il cuoricino non reggeva
c'è un vasellino,
botallo si chiama,
che di solito alla nascita si chiude,
ma qui era ovviamente aperto.
Il chirurgo ha detto:
"Arriviamo vicino al cuore
e lo chiudiamo con due mollette.
Ne facciamo tanti di interventi così,
abbiamo esperienza.
Ma se si rompe,
muore!"
(suono di dispositivo
per la ventilazione meccanica)
Ossigeno, per favore, ossigeno!
Allora, senti chirurgo, ascolta me:
questa operazione s'ha da fare
perché questa cannuccia nei polmoni
da sola non ce la fa più,
e poi vedrai che la togliamo,
ho capito che posso morire,
ma non mi hai mica detto
una cosa nuova!
E poi la mia mamma ormai
l'ho quasi conquistata.
Ho solo una richiesta:
le graffette, o luminose
come il cuore di Ironman,
o di adamantio come
lo scheletro di Wolverine...
se si può...
ossigeno, per favore!
Punto otto:
l'abbraccio.
Credetemi, non è
questione di fiducia.
Semmai di fede,
fede nell'energia che gira,
perché le mani
lavorano sempre sicure,
guidate da cervelli sapienti
e le macchine sono
instancabili, infallibili,
eppure, nella notte,
le termoculle scompaiono
(sospiro)
nell'inutile...
nell'inconsapevolezza del silenzio...
e non tornano più.
(sospiro)
Per questo, tutte le volte
che ho abbracciato una mamma
l'ho fatto per un secondo in più,
nel desiderio di essere io
a voler abbracciare,
nella speranza di non dover mai
essere abbracciata.
Mamma,
Doomsday è sceso una volta sola
per le strade di Metropolis,
ma bussa ogni giorno ai nostri oblò:
siamo guerrieri, sì, ma al suo cospetto,
davanti al Giorno del Giudizio,
l'intera Justice League e perfino
Superman sono caduti.
Di quelli che ci lasciano,
non ricordiamo solo il nome
e i dettagli,
ma portiamo la forza nel cuore
e se dovesse aprire,
sarà con quella che lo sfiderò.
Punto nove:
la pancia piena.
Signore in sala, qual'è la prima cosa
che chiedete alla maestra
quando andate a prendere i cuccioli
a scuolina?
Ha mangiato?
La mamma italiana
ha bisogno di sapere
che la pancia del proprio cucciolo
è sempre piena.
E finché quel pancino si riempiva
con un tubicino fino allo stomaco,
io dormivo più serena.
Una mattina, quel tubicino
non c'era più.
E la fame?
Quale fame?
Di chi?
Lasciami dormire...
lo sai molto bene che
mentre dormo
il mio cervellino si potenzia!
Non sono pigra,
mi sto allenando!
Non hai imparato niente da
Magneto, Doctor Strange e Professor X?
Punto dieci:
la notizia.
Signora, è ora di andare
tutti a casa.
A casa?
Sì, decidiamo una data di dimissione.
Dimissione?
Ma se fino a ieri aveva bisogno
di ossigeno,
non si sveglia mai per mangiare,
al biberon diventa blu
perché va in apnea,
al seno, si impegna da matti, eh!
Ma non ciuccia nulla,
come posso farla crescere?
Dai, mamma, non fare la tragica,
non sono mica dimagrita,
e poi, a casa, mica li perdo
i miei superpoteri,
sarà solo tutto un po' più...
normale!
E poi, non senti che casino,
gli allarmi, qui...
se mi prometti che a casa
c'è un po' più di silenzio,
andiamo a casa.
Signori,
io porto mia figlia nel cervello.
Nell'egoismo dell'amore,
del tempo, dei farmaci,
è dentro di me,
non la sento ma c'è.
Io la porto nelle orecchie,
nel terrore di non sentire
più il suo cuore;
nelle unghie, infilate nei palmi
ogni notte;
nei lividi da farmaci liquidi;
porto mia figlia nello stomaco,
buio, razionale, di una termoculla;
nella gola, perché sento
i suoi tubi nella mia;
e nei polmoni, perché lì
si blocca l'aria quando
il dolore manda in blackout
il cervello
e il cuore.
Io porto mia figlia
sulla pelle del torace,
perché respiri con me.
Sul seno, perché ogni giorno
consegnerò il mio legame di latte.
E con spalle più leggere,
quando anche solo 15 grammi
di tubo in meno
incidono sulla bilancia.
Io la porto sulle mani,
al fasciatoio,
perché lì posso sentire i suoi calci
sulla mia pancia da fuori,
e poi a casa,
dove la paura deforma
lo specchio del cuore
prima di guardarci il mondo attraverso.
Io la porto sulle ginocchia,
ad ogni pasto,
perché è più facile vedere
quando diventa blu
e poi, lei è sulla mia bocca
fra i baci, i sorrisi, le parole,
anche in questo momento.
E negli occhi, ogni istante
in cui non è con me.
Io la indosso
con la fascia, il marsupio,
il mei tai, le braccia,
preziosamente vestite
l'una dell'altra,
cuore a cuore,
occhi a occhi.
Ma lei cammina, da sempre,
due passi avanti a me
lasciandomi briciole di energia
a mostrare la strada.
Signori, porto mia figlia addosso,
anche se è lei che
ha sempre portato me.
(Applausi)
[Grazie...]